[Music]  Shay Mooney and Hannah Billingsley are  married  sources close to the pair confirmed to  ET the 25 year old singer and his  ladylove tied the knot on Friday during  an intimate ceremony surrounded by  friends and family at Shea's parents  family farm in Arkansas he also learned  the newlyweds are now honeymoon eing in  Cancun Mexico Hana posted this sweet  snap to Instagram of her brand-new  wedding bands announcing the vacation  had officially begun the couple who have  been together since 2014 became engaged  in August 2016 and welcomed their first  child together Asher in January 2017  congratulations to the happy couple  [Music]  you